speaking of public
health
a protestant pastor got in a whole lot
of trouble a few days ago his name is
mike todd
i don't know anything about mike todd i
don't know anything really about his
theology or his liturgy he got in
trouble because he spit on his hand and
rubbed it on
a member of his congregation's face
he trended we were told he's an idiot
this is crazy this is spooky he should
be locked away here is what
mike todd said and did
he's changing something and you don't
see it clearly yet
but you hit
[Applause]
and this is where
most people
would not face jesus anymore
[Applause]
what most people would do
is turn
away
[Music]
[Applause]
the vision i'm about to give you
it might get nasty
all right the cough was probably
unnecessary i will admit that was a
little bit gross but the idea of a
pastor rubbing saliva on a on a member
of the congregation's face
is actually not that weird when you look
at the christian tradition actually in
the traditional rite of baptism
that has existed in the catholic church
for many many centuries
the priest
has a little salive on his thumb and
rubs it on the nostrils and the ears of
the baby being baptized christ uses
saliva to spit in the dirt and rub it on
a man's face in the gospels it's not
that weird if you are familiar with
christianity
this guy mike todd i suspect i wouldn't
agree very much with his take on
theology and liturgy
but i don't really get what the big deal
is i guess the big deal is that we are
now living in a different religion we're
living under the cult of public health
where we're not even forget about
coughing in public forget about touching
someone especially with saliva
we're not even allowed to breathe
in the same room
we have to put masks on
we we can't we have to look at one
another as walking bags of germs that
are ready to kill us rather than as our
brothers in christ as our fellow human
beings
so i suspect the reason people reacted
so strongly against this
obviously he was trying to provoke a
reaction to begin with but the reason
people had such a reaction to this is
because we're living under the sway of a
different religion which
makes an idol out of your physical
health
even to the point of not not being
allowed to get sick anymore
you remember when people used to just
get sick sometimes and it was fine
remember when people used to have a cold
or the flu and it was just
fine like it wasn't pleasant but it was
okay that those days seem gone i my wife
and i joke now whenever we're on an
airplane or in a restaurant and i cough
just a little cough i'm not saying it's
a covenant cough i just cough she looks
at me she says you can't do that you're
going to get arrested
we're not allowed to do that anytime
someone
coughs or sneezes or has the sniffles
down
we say no that's
you've got to go away you've got to lock
yourself in your room until you're 100
percent
better are you spending too much money
on gas right now i know you are if you
live in america you are spending too
much money on gas well i've got a little
relief for you
that would be get upside get upside it's
a free app you go in you download the
free app and then you get 25 cents per
gallon cash back
every time you fill up your tank well
that's not quite true the first time you
fill up your tank you will actually get
50 cents per gallon cash back
if you use the code knowles canada wles
there's no catch
there's only cash back
it goes right into your bank account you
don't need to worry about it or if you
prefer you can get the money via paypal
you can get it through an e-gift card
for amazon and other companies or you
get it right into the bank account
everyone could use a little relief at
the pump these days you can get it if
you go to get upside you download that
app you use code knowles you will get up
to 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first fill up that is code knowles know
w l e s
just a little gift from me to you enjoy
amid all the craziness in our society
right now
a lovely little upside i'm glad you like
that clip
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe for free to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]